this video is sponsored by nordvpn
conventional wisdom tells us that we
shouldn't train every single day
conventional wisdom tells us that it'll
lead to burnout to over training to
injury well i've got just one thing to
say to that
screw conventional wisdom
just to be clear i'm all for proper
recovery in fact i recommend taking a
deload week at least once every six
weeks
but that doesn't mean you can't train at
all it just means you're going to back
off a little bit
i think this really comes down to how we
define training and what our goals are
but i think for the average person
actively discouraging any sort of
movement is a bad call
and yeah you shouldn't attempt your one
rep max on the squat or the bench press
every single day that's like asking
someone to run a marathon multiple times
a week a one rep maximum is max effort
by definition and this is something that
will severely tax the nervous system so
yes you'll need some time to recover or
training can be anything it can be
walking it can be light jogging it can
be play it can be working on skills
training can be five minutes of bouncing
a tennis ball against the wall great for
hand-eye coordination great for cardio
it can be a bit of shadow boxing to
practice your punching technique or it
could be a walk around the block doing
any of these things will get blood
flowing around your body burn calories
and provide your nervous system with the
important stimulus it needs to move
better and more safely
and now let's take a moment to talk
about today's sponsor nordvpn so nordvpn
is a vpn that's a virtual private
network what this is is it's a service
that allows you to route to your traffic
your internet traffic
via servers located around the world
this does is it hides your internet
browsing behavior from your isp your
internet service provider and at the
same time it also disguises your ip
address from the websites you're
visiting this is because as far as your
internet service provider is concerned
you're only visiting those servers and
as far as the websites are concerned
only those servers are visiting their
sites and because using the ip address
of servers located all around the world
you're also able to essentially convince
websites that you're coming from those
destinations what this means is that you
can access region locked content and
watch shows on sites like netflix that
wouldn't otherwise be available in your
country and the great thing is that
using nordvpn won't slow down your
traffic you won't experience buffering
because it has the fastest times as
compared with similar services according
to the latest speed tests and views of
this channel can get access to an
exclusive deal by going to nordvpn.com
forward slash the bioneer and that comes
with a 30 day money back guarantee so
there's no risk involved and thanks
again to nordvpn for sponsoring this
video and allowing me to make more of
the kind of content that i love to make
now on with the show and doing any of
these things will get blood flowing
around the body it'll burn calories
it'll wake up your muscles
in fact gentle walking or jogging or
skipping can actually encourage and
enhance recovery by getting more blood
supply to the muscles
this is another good reason to train in
multiple disciplines because it means
you have more options to choose from and
more different types of training you can
bounce between
and it also begs the question how
frequently should you be training with
max effort in the first place wouldn't
it be better to train a little bit more
frequently but a little less intensively
wouldn't that just be more natural now i
know there's lots of studies on this
lots of conflicting research as to
whether intensity or volume leads to
greater hypertrophy and strength gains
but i'm not talking about hypertrophy
this time i'm not talking about strength
gains for specific lift see this is
where i think a lot of youtube fitness
can actually miss the mark slightly
because these aren't the only yardsticks
the only metrics by which you measure
the success of a training program for
the average person who's more interested
in just general fitness and general
health maybe reducing their injuries
maybe performing a little bit better
training more frequently has a lot of
advantages and the perfect example of
this of course is the legendary farmer
strength we could equally call this
labourer strength or even that strength
or mum strength
sony works a physical job moving
furniture digging holes laying bricks
wrestling pigs again i'm not really sure
what farmers actually do for a living
well they're going to do that every day
or at least five days a week and guess
what most of them are in great shape
they're really strong and they don't
kill over dead at least not typically of
course they also don't look like pro
bodybuilders and they don't have amazing
numbers on the bench press so the
difference is that they aren't isolating
specific muscle groups they aren't
actively seeking out the recognized
stimuli that create muscle growth every
rep is slightly different so they're
training more broadly and because the
weight isn't so heavy there's lower
stakes to getting it wrong but here's
the thing they also probably don't put
their back out every few months they
generally have incredible grip strength
and they don't tire out and by the same
token if you ask a power lifter or a
bodybuilder to try and dig a massive
hole 10 days in a row the person who is
used to regular physical labor will do a
better job a much better job see they're
training the things that you don't see
they don't have the numbers to show for
it and they don't have the ripped
physique necessarily but they have
stronger thicker tendons remember
tendons have a lesser blood supply as
compared with muscle and they take much
longer to grow greater work capacity
extremely robust movement patterns that
actually translate to better work
they've greased the groove over
countless repetitions of those movements
with slight variations just to ensure
that they are also prepared for whatever
life might throw at them keep this in
mind with your own fitness journey don't
just look at numbers and metrics as they
only tell a tiny piece of the story
think about how much energy you have in
the mornings and at the end of the day
think about how confident you feel think
about how much easier certain tasks
might have been
how you bound up the stairs how you
unconsciously used perfect form when
lifting that bag off the floor think
about how this will translate to your
performance and fitness 10 20 50 years
from now we all know those wiry old guys
that are still way more practical and
physical than we are when it comes to
actual graft they got here over decades
of toughening thus their gains are more
resilient too this is a marathon not a
sprint don't just train for numbers
train for specific tasks skills and jobs
and train of course for the sheer fun of
it now i'm not saying you can't train
max effort because there are plenty of
people who have these physically
demanding jobs who still lift huge
numbers in the gym we can certainly
combine being more active with a strict
lifting regime as long as we ramp up the
volume and intensity slowly while
listening to our bodies
that said we do need to carefully
consider training in the context of
lifestyle we can't view training as this
special bubble that exists outside of
reality your ability to recover and your
physicality will be hugely impacted by
what you do outside of the gym and vice
versa
if you're not a professional power
lifter or bodybuilder then your
performance in the gym shouldn't be your
primary measure of health and fitness
the main point i want to drive home here
is that a single day of sitting or being
entirely sedentary is extremely bad for
you and if you're training if your coach
is encouraging this then you might want
to consider rebalancing some things it
sends whole muscle groups to sleep it
creates tightness and stiffness it makes
you sluggish and lethargic it slows down
your metabolism and your heart rate we
shouldn't avoid any form of training or
exercise between sessions because we're
afraid it's going to take away from our
next workout because doesn't that
entirely miss the point don't live to
work out work out to live
so you found this video useful
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like and share it around that
would help me out immensely let me know
in the comments down below what you
think where do you draw that line
between training and just being more
active and how regularly do you take
rest days what do you view as a rest day
if you like this approach to training
that looks at overall performance not
just numbers on lifts or the way you're
looking then you might enjoy my ebook
and training program super functional
training 2.0 the protein performance
system that's an 80 plus page ebook a
complete training routine and over two
hours of video tutorials showing how to
do all of the moves yeah check it out
link in the description if that sounds
interesting either way thank you so much
for watching this one guys and i'll see
you next time
bye for now